Iran is looking to return to the global
bond markets for the first time in 14
years it's seeking to finance an
economic recovery after the lifting of
international sanctions the economy
minister ali tyeb Nia says he expects
her on to secure a credit rating in the
near future a step that could help
attract bond investors happy onam xemina
body enters right now the groundwork for
issuing bonds and various Iranian debt
securities and international markets
exists and I'm certain this situation
will also improve in the future we have
something like 45 billion dollars worth
of signed agreements with different
countries for financing Iranian projects
from on the story we're joined by
Bloomberg's laden nursery Ladon what's
the reasoning behind this latest move
well you have to see that Iran had been
starved from investment for almost a
decade and and it badly needs cash so
that's the first reason and you know why
is it turning to Asia at this point
because even at the height of sanctions
when you have European countries that
shunt Iran Asian companies were the ones
who were present and you know at that
time when I was in Iran it wasn't
unusual to see Chinese businessman south
korean businessman they were present
they were involved in transportation
they were involved in different projects
so it's only natural that at this point
in one would think that you know there
could be interest from this marcus and
his Messrs but despite the nuclear deal
being signed Ladon Iran is not back to
business as usual give us some examples
here well I mean general if we look at
the situation there is a number of deals
that have been signed but they have yet
to be finalized and I have yet to be
funded so you know we can we can think
of a number of this but but you know the
reason for that is that the US sanctions
are still present so even the companies
who want to be involved in your and have
to navigate through a series of of
existing restrictions and you know so
European banks have you know yet to
fully embrace you know and return to
Iran so an example also is the case of
Boeing where we're seeing this because
the political wrangling in the
us in an election year you know we're
seeing this deal who's valued at 17
billion being threatened